[Musique]
crochet avant crochet suivi crochet
genou de la tue pas rend carrousel puis
10 tours et enveloppements
- 40% ça fait cent soixante
je veux juste pouvoir aider ma
grand-mère faire un peu de shopping de
temps en temps quand j'étais petit je
voulais travailler avec les animaux
ce que je fais lauber tous ces sales
types de wall street
vous avez vu ce qu'ils ont fait notre
pays il vole vraiment tout le monde les
pauvres travailleurs en tout perdu et
pas un seul de ces salopards a été en
tout le jeu truqué les gens qui suivent
les règles peuvent pas gagner
[Musique]
c'est un peu comme braquer une banque
sauf qu'on a les clés vous en êtes
adam voici mes collègues des chats s'il
vous plaît et si l'un d'eux a fait les
flics pour dire quoi
j'ai claqué cinq mille dollars dans un
club de strip tease il me faut la police
on est une famille maintenant
et une famille blindés
à quel moment vous diriez que ça a
dérapé
[Musique]
elle met il y est retourné trois autres
fois ça lui plaisait
[Musique]
ce budget
on a regardé mal d'ailleurs tony vous
laisserai pas faire thiers jules
prévenir mais qui lui a rendu soit
portable
[Musique]